hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it so you don't have to pour M
night Shyamalan and I mean that here's a
guy who peeked far too early was built
up as one of the great directors after
only doing a few films and obviously had
way too many ideas that weren't
thought-out enough and kept getting
green-lighted however it's M night
Shyamalan likes to say looks like it was
meant to be but everyone has the same
question when did the slippery slope of
a sneeze begin some say was with the
village others say was with the
happening but for me I think it all goes
back to the invasion of the plot holes
signs yeah I know the movie was a big
hit when it came out yeah I know the
critics liked it yeah I know the
magazines were calling sha Millan the
next Spielberg after and premiered yeah
seriously the next feel Bert you called
that one Newsweek yeah I know a ton of
people did and still really really enjoy
this film but you don't know anything
you're doing you think you don't know
any better
okay it's not well written it's not well
directed it's not well acted it's not
well okay so let me enlighten you as to
why this film is not well this is signs
we open with Mel Gibson when his name
was proud to be pleased about the title
as opposed to being shamefully shoved
into the and category as he wakes up to
the sound of his daughter screaming his
brother played by Joaquin Phoenix also
goes out to check the trouble Oh where's
Morgan oh I am my dream Chan
Morgan what's happening Dodger barking
oh gosh uh ah yes see that bland
non-expressive dead face that only a
Culkin can give you get used to that
folks there's a lot of it in the rest of
this movie so they see that there are
crop circles in the middle of their
fields wait why did that warrant the
little girl going at this dumped corn
really frightened her that much
and okay directing 101 it usually helps
if you tell us the name of the place
before you give us five minutes of a
scene it's like an alien suddenly saying
Danny Pete sicky-sick once you take him
outside I'll call dr. Crawford he
doesn't change I don't know what to do
yeah come on dog anatomy is pretty close
to human anatomy right oh that was quick
Carolina I only called you folks two
hours ago
Oh mrs. Kendal but twisted her ankle as
she puts that diving for her life was a
bunch of school kids rode down the
sidewalk on skateboards she went down to
Thornton store this morning and started
spittin on the new skateboards spittin
by the time I got there mrs. Kettleman
had sprayed the whole damn place
forgive me what I'm doing is called
Tarantino Inge where you talk about
something that has nothing to do with
the rest of the story but is kind of
funny and a little quirky
it was very avant-garde in its day and
used to develop some strong character
traits but now it's just you as as a
cheap gimmick for pretentious
screenwriters to draw a ton of attention
to their writing style as opposed to
serving the plot by the way I'm mostly
pointless in this
I don't even draw my gun in this movie
aliens attacking and I never draw my gun
that is a shit meanwhile his two kids
find that their dog is acting a little
funny
bow don't run strong boy stop it mania
what careful dog you might get that
Culkin to slightly open his eyes a
little don't even get me started on the
possibilities overloading some animals
around the county been acting funny
it's another violent what is it upon us
I don't think so father Caroline please
stop calling me Father
what's wrong I don't hear my children
Thank You mr. line mm-hmm uh here we go
uh Mel Gibson turns as if something is
wrong as he says the line I think
something is wrong which gives the cop
reason to ask what's wrong seriously
directing 101 fell on me want to kill
both so wait a minute a crop circle gets
the girl going yeah but when a dog tries
to attack her she sits calmly with her
legs folded for that matter
Gibson caught the absence of his kids
whispering in the distance yet the
stabbing of a violent animal somehow
didn't catch his ear he can pick up but
he can't pick up what about selective
hearing no well maybe it's the fact that
there's so much goddamn low-level
whispering in this movie that the actual
absence of it seems legitimately
startling looks like it was meant to me
that night Gibson is woken up by another
disturbance maybe he can't hear the
crickets chirping there's a monster
outside my room as a classroom blogger
my god his black suit spider-man stop
him before he does a tap dance routine
we both go outside move around the house
and opposite directions we act crazy in
the same thing you're making crap in
their pants for some rounds we meet up
on the other side explain that crazy no
I don't know what's something like this
they see garbage spilled over but then
somehow black suit spider-man got to the
roof again yes
alien report stepped on roof and swung
on swing very confusing mission
accomplished will now go to Arkansas to
put toast in toaster and slide down
slide they call the cop in the morning
and we partake in yet another favorite
of sha Milan's the pointless pan across
so how are you Meryl
Oh huh how was work at the gas station
stimulating I never got a chance to tell
you but now here's the thing with these
kind of shots these can work if they're
trying to get across an uncomfortable
mood or unworldly environment but
through most of the movie we're in
everyday farmland which obviously isn't
that scary and these shots are done
during non suspenseful moments so once
again it just serves to shove the style
in our faces as opposed to actually get
us engrossed in the situation but don't
worry there's still plenty of needlessly
slow dialogue to suck you back in how
certain are you that this was a male oh
I don't know any girls who could run
like that
I don't know male I've seen some of
those women on the Olympics they can run
like the wind
this guy got on our roof in like a
second our roof is 10 feet high
they have women's high jumping in the
Olympics I got these Scandinavian women
who can jump clean over me
okay we're sexist dicks who don't watch
the Olympics will you arrest something
aliens didn't think we see those in this
movie up science first emerged in the
late 70s with renewed interest in
extraterrestrial life they died out by
the early eighties dismissed as hoaxes
this new resurgence is wholly different
the speed and the quantity in which it
has appeared implies the coordination of
hundreds of individuals over many
countries either this is one of the most
elaborate hoaxes ever created or
basically it's for real that's right
people years ago did crop circles as an
elaborate hoax to convince people that
aliens were real but in a frigging
unbelievable coincidence
the real aliens had the exact same way
of communicating as those hoaxes what
are the fucking odds the strike was
meant to be the next day they all go
into town to run some errands and we
figure out from poor exposition that
Gibson used to be a reverend right after
another pointless van shot
it was asthma medicine right father
Morgan has and it's not father anymore
we also get some amazingly hokey acting
from this general guy after you guessed
it I've had two separate folks tell me
they're been strangers around these
parts last couple nights can't tell what
they look like because they're staying
in the shadows covert like nobody's been
hurt mind you and that's the giveaway
it's a military procedure send out a
reconnaissance group very small check
things out not to engage but to evaluate
the situation evaluate the level of
danger oh I apologize I don't really
talk this way I'm just auditioning for
our Twilight Zone episode that's the get
away make sure things are all clear
clear for what
for the rest of them what are you
sucking on your mom's teat close your
lips you weirdo Disney's Hall of
Presidents is more natural than you shit
I know you your barrel Hess mm I was
there the day you hit that 507 footer
over the left-field wall
hmm set the record hmm and that thing
had a motor mm still the record right mm
got the bat at home why weren't you in
the pros making stacks of cash and
getting your toes licked by beautiful
women toes look you'll get much hair off
this guy he's waving me out I mean he's
the alien in this movie he has the
minor-league strikeout record hello Lana
Romero's like class a screw-up you just
swing that bat as hard as you could
every time didn't matter what the
coaches said didn't matter who was on
base you just whip that back to the air
as hard as you could
thanks person who clearly has a
connection to Joaquin Phoenix though we
don't know what it is and we will never
see again I will not miss you looks like
it was meant to me they need for lunch
in a restaurant when we come across
another staple of M night Shyamalan M
night Shyamalan he plays the man who
accidentally ran over Gibson's wife
hence the reason Gibson lost his faith
but that's brushed aside for another
scene where he hears some noise and his
crops again you know for a guy who
apparently owns all these fields you
never seem to any farm work I'm not
gonna report this or anything you do to
my crops to the news or TV or anybody
oh my god he's being invaded by Kermit
the Frog hey I understand you haven't
subscribed to the Muppet YouTube channel
yet don't make me shove the Rainbow
Connection up your ass it's not easy
being dead why dad you look so dramatic
I never see you like this let's turn on
the TV they decide to finally turn on
the TV and see that the aliens are
indeed landing or just hovering around
in the skies for a bit why nobody
approaches them or takes them down is
anybody's guess my ballet recital listen
Bo this is very important everything
people have written about in science
books is going to change the history of
the world's future is on the TV right
now we need to record the shake and show
your children this tape and say you were
there
for your children Bo what kid talks like
this it's like a fucking real old
version of Morpheus you're here because
you know something what do you know you
can't explain what you feel it you felt
it your entire life but there's
something wrong with the world you don't
know what it is but it's there like a
splinter in your mind driving you mad
it is this healing is rocky to me whoa
this image has not been adjusted or
enhanced in any way what you're seeing
is real it's unbelievable everything
they wrote in science books is about to
change okay so we're in a world where
the children talk like adults and the
adults talk like children let's hear
some more of that jolting unrealistic
talk shall we
you said there are two reasons you want
extraterrestrials or visit us to make
contact in the spirit of exploration and
furthering the knowledge of the universe
or the other reason they're hostile well
if mankind is as emotionally dead as you
are I don't think they'll learn much
from us oh well these credible
kindergarten drawings will certainly
convey the seriousness of the books
intent
oh there's also drawing up their house
on fire in the book with three dead
people that look like them outside my
god this obviously means wait no what
does this mean the author knows they're
going to die
met them before and do an illustration
of the quicker distraction before you
think about too much that'll do the
trick let's see what my tea is up to
here never fallen asleep driving before
it had to be at that right moment that
10 15 seconds when I passed her walking
was like it was meant to be I know
that's not the best thing for a murderer
to tell a murder victim's husband but
what can I say him a bad writer he's
places marked and crops and such none of
them are really near water I don't think
they like water did you see something
right I'm truly sorry for what I've done
to you and yours don't open my pantry
father I found one of them in there
locked him in okay let's try this
conversation again you start with holy
shit I got an alien in my house to call
the cops to call the FBI
call the news the world deserves to know
then you move on to oh by the way I'm
sorry I hit your wife like I was playing
a game of Crazy Taxi this would be
closer to a typical human reaction
something Shyamalan like the aliens
knows very little about hello Gibson
goes in to try and sneak a peek but
these giant aliens somehow slip their
teeny tiny hands through the bottom of
the door and try to attack it go with
God motherfucker
aah and a good manicurist rather than
call the police because that's what
anyone not in a shamble on film would do
he goes home and sees everybody
continues to watch TV this video was
taken yesterday afternoon
son seventh birthday in the city of
passo fundo Brazil all initial opinions
are this is genuine what you're about to
see may disturb you boy there's a lot of
build-up for this I can't wait to see
the incredibly scary and of course
original design of this thing oh my god
like every other alien I've ever seen in
every other movie
whoa ground forces have been assembled
in countries throughout the globe
hundreds of thousands have flocked to
temples synagogues and churches God be
with us all well good job to the
newscasters for not spreading panic or
alarm when have you ever heard a
newscaster talk like this
what kind of overly emotional fear
driven news corporation acts like that
you know that was Kevin so the family
decides to hold down the fort
you know stay in the area where they
absolutely know the aliens are and try
to defend themselves we're going to
board up every window in this house out
of hell ports we'll do anything because
they seem to have trouble with pantry
doors really Shawn what did you read
that line out loud did did you ever read
that line out loud you killing it you
you clearly cut out I mean you just
stated that these technologically
advanced aliens these creatures that we
are supposed to be afraid of cannot get
through pantry doors they can build
spacecraft that can jump millions of
miles across space but they seem to have
trouble with pantry doors they can take
these exact same spacecrafts and turn
them invisible so that nobody else can
find those years above our technology
but they seem to have trouble with
pantry doors they're gonna take over a
planet but they seem to have trouble
with pantry doors they're going to wipe
out Oh kind but they seem to have
trouble with pantry doors you can't be
this stupid
I mean you literally just say it out
loud why this movie can't work you Maura
hey I hate to borrow from a subpar
comedy but change its Terry movie three
they mastered Space Flight but they
can't get through a wooden door you see
what you did there mommy did you see
what you did you just make Charlie Sheen
write about something you did that movie
dad I'd imagine gun this steadfast and
logically holy shit-fuck race of aliens
stop come to a halt by a fucking pan
Cherie
so they board up the windows with one
because hey pantry doors are made out of
one it seems to be their Achilles heel
and as you'd expect the aliens cannot
fucking get past it
seriously I give anything to see what
these aliens are saying when they
actually do start their attack is wrong
order
Tori Oh God we're all Archie you're not
Google Oh Donna
fuck God I did that I won't move move
along with that eateth a bendable
wrong-o
peanut Esau gone wrong you know what
happened when you were born Morgan oh
dang and your mama kept bleeding so the
doctors rest you out of the room before
I even had time to see that sauna there
on the roof
don't go Isabella while they were fixing
her up
while she kept asking about was you
there in the house I wanted your mama to
see you first because she had dreamed
about you I mentioned a feeling better
they brought you in and they placed you
in her arms
o Lord of your role and you looked at
her and you just stared each other for
the longest time ah yeah God not-not-not
it she said real soft hello Morgan
I'm your mama just how I dreamed Coco
ship smoke nothing bad in the night Anna
oh boy so they hide in the basement but
thank God another door is there to
protect them oh go fuck Nick God but one
of them gets the bright idea to try and
grab the kid from the window which calls
us into heaven asthma attack but luckily
the father is there and manages to
calming down after spending the night
down there yeah they never figured out
how to get through the door they hear on
the radio that apparently the aliens
were defeated and here's a big shock
they were defeated very quickly no their
tactical maneuvers were so flawless as
only two just don't put any doors in
their way they're practically invincible
some bring the TV but what do you know
one bullet worked
however in a totally forced flashback we
see Gibson talked to his wife for the
last time who was pinned against a tree
just taking a walk before dinner you
know thanks thanks for reminding her
that for me to play games did you of
play it's okay to be silly hey Bill did
you of Scilly tell Grimm tell him to see
if you won't see me till your 220 came I
would be coming home this Christmas yes
at the time it didn't make sense
but now Gibson knows that the term
swing-away was I swear to god I'm not
kidding here God's Way of telling Gibson
in the future that Joaquin Phoenix is
supposed to swing his bat to defeat the
alien no swing-away of course who would
have possibly put together that the best
way to defeat this thing was to beat the
shit out of it nobody could have come to
that conclusion obviously God had to
kill a reference wife in order for
somebody to figure that out
it just makes perfect sense oh and you
wanna know what the big twist was in
this one apparently the only thing that
can kill the aliens is water yeah it's
like acid - one drop hurts them like
crazy hmm probably should have thought
that through before attacking a planet
nicely covered in water my god we were
afraid of these things they have three
major easily accessible weaknesses water
wood and blunt instruments hell if God
really wanted to get his message across
he would have had his dying wife say hey
this is gonna sound a little crazy but
if aliens attack go get a lake house he
thinks she was crazy like he already did
before but hey when aliens attacked that
both home is suddenly looking
affordable isn't it unfortunately the
aliens sprayed the kid with poison gas
but luckily his lungs were closed due to
the asthma so he's okay
that's right the message of the story is
that everything has and always will fall
perfectly into place the day is saved
everything happens for a reason which
means that his faith is restored and he
goes back to being a reverend gotta hand
it to you God you do work in mysterious
ways for in the grand plan he took
Gibson's faith away just so he could
give it right back to him so in reality
nothing has changed at all except a
visit dead-white depicts if it but still
thank you God thank you for killing my
beloved just so everything could go back
to exactly the way it was before
again mine is the loving supporting wife
that you so cruelly took away from me
but hey I'm sure that was all part of
your plan to keep things exactly the way
they were mine is the loving supportive
wife that you took away from me but I
know in your plan you wanted everything
to go this way which is exactly how it
was before again - the loving supportive
wife that you took away from me but I
know that you get God's fucked up he
plans ahead about as much as he's
dumbass aliens - or let's be honest here
and nice shallow hot dogs I'm sorry but
this movie's horrible I never got why so
many people liked it it's overly
dramatic annoyingly slow has a real ego
when it comes to its own style and of
course any sense of logic is totally
ignored there's millions of other twins
you could have done to this movie like
how about the aliens were trying to help
people like bring them a cure or
something or maybe there were no aliens
it was all in elaborate hoax
that would have been unexpected or hell
maybe none of this was going on and
Gibson in Phoenix were just goddamn nuts
hell maybe the TV was never even on
no just anything is better than today
like water and it turns out they don't
like water
don't you just send your twist in the
first half of the movie don't even know
that makes it a twist know what's really
scary about this movie bet so many
goddamn people enjoyed it as trouble
honest tell getting work because of it
I've missed our critic Irie man
excuse me I gotta
so many goddamn people enjoyed it and
some on is still get aliens
what's liked was mentally
you